now for years indigenous bolivian women
have been trying to make inroads into
traditionally male domains like
mountaineering in the andes it was only
recently that they started guiding
tourists up the country's high peaks and
glaciers now a group of women have
played a football match on ice and snow
on the summit plateau at a record
altitude of 5 800 meters to draw
attention to their cause
here's more now on how this
extraordinary match came about
bolivia's glaciers in the andes a
majestic site
their summits seem unreachable
a group of women has made it their
mission to conquer these peaks
with coca leaves and cigarettes these
indigenous women climbers give an
offering to mother nature before their
ascent
i used to be a porter for tourists
carrying their stuff to the huts
in the beginning we were discriminated
against people thought that women
wearing skirts couldn't climb up there
women from the aimara ethnic group have
been guiding tourists to the peaks for
seven years at over five thousand meters
the air is thin and today they're
attempting to make a record
we haven't slept much but we're still
full of energy
[Music]
long live the indigenous women
climbers their goal to play soccer on
the roof of the world on the andes at
dawn
the summit plateau has an altitude of 5
800 meters
they solemnly carry the bolivian flag
over the icy ground
then it's kickoff
indigenous women have never played
soccer at this altitude before
even the experienced female climbers are
a little breathless for the fast sprints
but they have a lot of fun breaking the
altitude record and scoring a goal for
women
[Music]